sebastiano campari fare risponde poi
iniziare un blog e cantando a natale
puoi e a natale
[Musica]
fare quello che non puoi fare ma
è la suite i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo in un nuovo blog come solito
ragazzi prima di cominciare iniziamo con
la fan art della settimana e 30 ragazzi
non metto se non mi sbaglio da dicembre
perché da secoli che non faccio blog
comunque la fa nate della settimana è
stata vinta da sofia ha fatto un
capolavoro ragazzi come ha scritto
400.000 iscritti è la cosa più epica del
mondo e poi ragazzi e somigliante in una
maniera che è veramente impressionante
ci abbiamo provato e che roba mi fa male
la mascella comunque ragazzi veramente
ci tengo a fare dei complimenti assurdi
a a questa questa picasso dei tempi
moderni perché come cazzo
possibile che vi somiglia più con la nel
disegno che io stesso da ripassare alle
news prima di passare ovviamente all'os
cartaccia dei pacchi perché lo sono
state aspettando
come se fosse l'ultima cosa dalla vostra
vita non aspettate nati ma avrebbero
dato ragazzi che siamo ripartiti con i
video e siamo non lo so adesso sono
partito con una carica incredibile
perché abbiamo bisogno di prendervi le
vacanze di natale perché ero abbastanza
stanchi quel periodo perché tra scuola
canale è un casino di cose che stanno
succedendo in questo periodo che avevo
veramente bisogno di prendermi in un
attimino una settimana per me perché ero
stremato per tutto quanto la cosa mi è
servita parecchio perché adesso sono
carichissimo per ricominciare come si
deve e allarme per il video di ieri
ragazzi che dopo due ore di
registrazione ho scoperto felicemente
che non mi ha registrato moto o no e
questo è stato più o meno la mia razione
durante il video su altri ragazzi siamo
arrivati a circa 420 mila iscritti che è
un traguardo allucinante che c'è io non
ho parole veramente grazie di cuore è la
cosa che vi voglio dire che sto
iniziando a pensare al traguardo allo
speciale dei 500mila e ovviamente e
mezzo milione di iscritti un qualcosa di
impressionante quindi voglio fare uno
speciale coi fiocchi ragazzi e sto
pensando a una cosa che pero riuscire a
fare entro i 500 mila però non ne sono
sicuro ragazzi perché assicuro che prima
di preparare il tutto arrivano e non so
se riesco a farcela forse si è detto
questo ragazzi credo di avervi scarto
aver tratti mar oms come si deve e direi
che possiamo passare allo scarpaccio dei
pacchi
[Musica]
chiamato un dottore perché sto prendendo
il braccio si vabbè ragazzi prima di
perdere un arto deciso di scartare nei
quattro ai quali c'è anche una busta
ragazze non è da lì che cosa sia ma
comunque partirà il primo che il più
piccolino anche più leggero
ci ha messo qua dentro un ovetto kinder
raga non è gradito da siena comunque mi
sa che si è aperto
madonna quanta violenza lega questi
pacchi che cazzo aspettate un attimo una
lattina della coca cola con su scritto
il bip e trenta ragazzi credo che con il
vip si riferisca a lui quindi very
important pupazzo in poche parole dice
questo ragazzi che dice metti dentro i
tuoi ricordi
devo mettere qui dentro mi ricordi a voi
ragazzi direi di passare a questo rosso
enorme che tra l'altro una donna è una
cosa incredibile ma che ca o zio è un
album di figurine dei pokémon meno di
sei ragazzi ma perché diavolo mi metto
inviato un album di figurine
ordinatissimo tra l'altro che se io
avessi ricevuto st scatola quando avevo
10 anni probabilmente a quest'ora ero
fuori casa a nudo in mutande che girava
e saltellavo per la piazza di shanghai è
un bracciale con i dadi 2 mutel e poi
c'è quello che davo una nutella e poi
c'è questo cosa che penso è che stile
no mi chiamò madonna guardalinee roba
che a macchia che figo ragazzi se non
avete presente la sbronza
diciamo che è più o meno così e direi di
passare al prossimo parco perché sono
curiosissimo di vedere che diavolo anche
questo che è il più grande di tutti tra
l'altro oggi
ok anche a questo punto si era strappati
i vestiti io ho strappato della carta a
recarci che vedete che ci ha paura di
vedere che diavolo c'è qui dentro questa
che cosa diavolo dovrebbe essere ragazzi
da adesso in avanti non è più un po vj a
condurre vivo ma è roba lì dentro sta
roba sto morendo di caldo comunque una
gamba pu la gamba non sono stato io non
sono stato io là fuori che c'è gli input
pazzo di su motori in una busta che dopo
aprirò fantastico l pizzi e super gli
occhi e soprattutto la faccia fantastica
complimenti per il make up e fini
ragazzi c'è il ringraziamento va vigente
alla terza di scientifico di piacenza
fantastico sei grande e ti vogliamo bene
ma vi voglio bene anch'io
ditemi se questa non è fottutamente arte
e fantastico ragazzi complimenti siete
meravigliosi e vi ringrazio per per la
gamma poche ragazzi temere una pena
anche questo che non ho capito che cos'è
perché è un tipo una busta quindi credo
sia una banhart ma solo per scrivere che
diavolo è perché non ci voglio credere
che è quello elly è uno dei disegni più
belli che mi siano mai arrivati e quello
che avevo postato tempo fa direttamente
il file originale ti ringrazio da morire
è veramente ragazzi la cosa più strana
non c'è anche l'altro no che sì
raga io io io non veramente rimango
senza parole quando vedo le cose rimango
senza parole dumber mizuki art c'è il
bigliettino da visita ragazzi questa
ragazza è un genio se io non so come
fanno a fare dei disegni così c'è chi
aveva dei dubbi che questo fosse una
foto perché alcuni me l'hanno scritto
favi ma questa è una [ __ ] foto che
sembra un disegno invecchia ignote
ragazzi credo che gli appenderò qua
dietro adesso vedo bene dove metto lì
dunque sono meravigliosi ed è per questo
ragazzi direi che possiamo passare alla
lettura delle domande quindi fa vi
risponde fa vi risponde favi ti prego
fai la sigla di james bond
[Musica]
super western 2000 fate risponde ma
perché la gente ti regala nutella e la
maggior parte della gente non sa perché
hai la nutella fobia però il problema è
che c'è io non ho mai detto nessuno o la
nutella fobia io in un video che mi pare
avevo registrato circa praticamente
quasi un anno fa avevo detto mentre
primo dei cassetti in un indie horror
dove la nutella mi era uscita così una
battuta sul momento e niente da lì la
gente non so perché esplosa con la
nutella e me la porta avanti da un anno
sta cosa ma io non solo nutella fobico
me la mangio a colazione pranzo cena ci
va beh insomma come persone normali
appoggia kirkham anche i troppi messaggi
subliminali con la parola pacco io non
so questa ragazza dovete uscita fuori
perché ma coi con normalissima mente ma
quindi è una cosa che tecnica già pagani
facebook e non è assolutamente la
coperta comune era fuori di sfondo e fai
un video in un altro luogo della casa
[Musica]
italiani capeggiati causata prima idea
i ragazzi direi che posso concludere qui
blog comunque siamo ripartiti con i
video tranquillamente spero veramente di
cuore che usciranno videogiochi
fantastici perché ne sto aspettando
tantissimi o delle aspettative è
veramente altissime per quest'anno
perché deve uscire di tutto ha fatto
tutto quello che uscirà di sicuro ci
saranno delle cose assurde quindi
aspettatevi di tutto ciò anche ragazzi
ed i due è piaciuto come al solito
lasciando un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovate nella descrizione sera siete
rischi di scrivetemi ci rimettiamo il
prossimo video ragazzi